Tom Cruise jumped off a cliff on a
motorcycle to get Mission Impossible
dead reckoning made but was it worth it
here's what the critics are saying
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part 1
sees Ethan Hunt Embark in his most
dangerous Adventure yet but he thrives
in these types of situations in this one
however the Unstoppable Action Hero must
travel the globe to track down a super
weapon and prevent it from falling into
the wrong hands the stakes are higher
than ever and the movie lives up to its
lofty Ambitions according to critics as
of the making of this video Mission
Impossible dead reckoning part 1 boasts
an impressive 97 score on Rotten
Tomatoes with most critics highlighting
Cruz's Daredevil Antics and the action
set pieces as standout moments in
looper's review Dominic Griffin compared
Cruz to a superhero who goes above and
beyond for the Cinematic art form and it
shows in its latest Blockbuster if Ethan
is the living manifestation of Destiny
then cruises the same before the spirits
of Cinema it will keep the big screen
experience alive and line his
considerably thick Pockets or die trying
this sentiment represents a general
consensus for director Christopher
McQueary and Tom Cruise's latest
action-packed collaboration without in
mind let's take a look at some of the
other reviews for the seventh
installment of the mission impossible
franchise between Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny underperforming and the
Flash bombing at the box office 2023
Summer movie season isn't exactly
booming that said some critics are
confident that the latest Mission
Impossible sequel will drag audiences
back into theaters for a good time
comicbookmovie.com's Rohan Patel is One
reviewer who believes that mission
impossible dead reckoning part 1
delivers the goods as the summer
spectacle calling it The Undisputed
Blockbuster movie event of the summer
Tom Cruise delivers yet another action
movie Masterpiece packed with
jaw-dropping spectacle pulse-pounding
action lots of Parts a scene stealing
Haley Atwell and everything you love
about Mission elsewhere desereto
reviewer Cameron Prue believes that this
is the type of movie that was designed
to provide the ultimate theatrical
experience furthermore the reviewer is
of the opinion that it's one of 2023's
best releases Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part 1 is an enthralling year
defining action picture this is what the
big screen was made for these viewpoints
were also echoed by the rap's Thomas
laughley who praised the film as top
tier Blockbuster entertainment that
allows Tom Cruise to put on a show what
better Mission could there be this
summer other than witnessing or
Perpetual cinematic Maverick deliver yet
another full-scale cinematic experience
long-running movie franchises always run
the risk of causing fatigue as such they
must continually find new ways to keep
fans interested while simultaneously
delivering the Hallmarks that audiences
want to see with Mission Impossible dead
reckoning part 1 Christopher McQueary
has up the ante in terms of spectacle
but the movie also boasts some fresh
ideas some critics praise the movie for
tapping into contemporary issues such as
the rise of artificial intelligence even
if it does explore these ideas in an
implausible way the world is changing
truth is Vanishing USA today's Brian
Truitt believes that action Buffs will
enjoy the Sci-Fi sprinklings in between
the high octane cinematic spectacle if
you choose to accept this Mission and
one action movie fan or Cruise nerd
wouldn't really it's the first half of a
man vs machine epic that doesn't skimp
in the Thrills Department that being
said while the movie does embrace
current technological themes it's still
a throwback picture in many ways and
that's a good thing the independence
Clarice Lowry wrote in her four-star
review the film is a mirror image of its
star a muscular extravagant thoroughly
old-school work of Ingenuity and craft
overall most Rotten Tomatoes critics are
of the opinion that mission impossible
dead reckoning part 1 is another winning
entry in the movie series that keeps
setting very high standards for itself
[Music]